um okay so just review of things that we
have done so um we're looking at
estimation estimating distribution of
the alphabet of size k
and uh we're asking
how well can you estimate those
distributions with n samples okay
and on the first day
we
started by um
looking at um what happens when you make
no assumptions
so you just want to estimate the
distribution you don't know anything and
then you said um you can look at the
empirical frequency estimator and in
terms of l1
it will achieve roughly square root of k
over n that's going to be your distance
and we said and this is also the best
you can do
um and we said that that's not very good
because it just goes like one over
square root of n so the number of
samples you need is quadratic which goes
very large very fast
okay uh so then this on the second day
we said okay what can we do to avoid
this growth and we said one one thing
that people do is assume some structure
on the distribution
um and for example we gave the example
of a monotone and envelope classes so
for example for monotone you'll see that
it will instead of k
you already go start going from low case
so it's
a lot faster
okay and
and then yesterday
we said what if you don't want to make
assumptions of the distribution you
don't want to assume that it's monotone
for example
and then we said what you could do is
maybe you could change your criteria
criterion a little bit instead of
estimating exactly the distribution just
do just estimate the probabilities of
things that appear at any given number
of time
which is in some sense anyway the best
you can do because you cannot
distinguish between them and we said
that once you do that then um we said
you could look at good touring and some
modification of good touring and then
you have you get a new estimator and it
be it
um it approximates uh the this this
combined probabilities at a rate of one
over n to the one quarter so now k
disappears completely from the picture
okay so there's no dependency on on k so
it applies to all alphabets any
distribution and even infinite elements
and what we want to do to do today is we
want to talk about some applications
and
include things like classification
and other things and our properties and
distributions and maybe a little bit
talk about continuous distributions
um and the approach that we'll take is
that of competitive so we're trying to
do something that is as good as
essentially as good as one any what
anyone can do okay so that's that's
that's our approach today
all right um okay so the first
application we'll talk about is
classification
so um
um so let's start with a simple example
so you have uh two
this descriptive distribution p and q
alphabet size k
the unknown and you get some training
samples from from p you get some
sequence x of length n and from q you
get another sequence y of length and
draw an iid according to p q
and then you get some z which is
distributed which is drawn either
according to p or according to q you
don't know which and for simplicity we
assume that they're equally likely
someone flips a coin gives you an ex
takes either pure q and selects an
example from p or for q according to
the distribution
all right
and the question is uh whether
z was generated by p or by q
okay
and so let's do a few examples here so
suppose we take three samples so p will
generate x1 up to x3 q will generate a
sequence y of length three and then
we'll get z okay so for example suppose
that
the p generated the sequence aab and q
generated the sequence bcb
and now we get a so most likely we'll
say that
z was generated according to p or
according q
obviously according to p thank you
so because it's closer to this to the x
sequence so generate according to p now
suppose we see b as z what would we say
most people would say
obviously
u and they'll be correct uh and if we
get c again
it's reasonable to assume that's
generated accordingly similar to y it's
a generator point
and let's say we get d
then maybe we we don't know
okay so here we go
this is what we're doing
so what are the applications of this
poem uh so for example spam filtering uh
you get a lot of samples of um of spam
mail and a lot of samples of
legitimate mail
and then the new mail comes in you want
to say is it legitimate or is it um
or uh your netflix you see a lot of
movies that someone liked and a lot of
movies that that person did not like and
you you want to
you want to decide whether you want to
recommend to them
some movies so try to see if this new
movie is more like what they liked or
didn't medical diagnosis
sick
people healthy people a new person comes
or or different diseases if you want a
new person comes a new symptoms you want
to classify
uh stock recommendations good stocks bad
stocks and so on a lot of different
things and you know you could argue yes
so i'm just thinking about the examples
you get right for the first two
isn't everything gonna come out like d
i mean
like in for spam filtering or movie
selection isn't every in case you say
you you have some movies the person
likes and this person doesn't like here
comes a new movie
it's going to be a new movie
so i'm sorry so
maybe this is not like uh it doesn't
follow exactly this thing but the
assumption is that
um there's a distribution you know the
movie movies made by of course if you
knew that ahead of time but there were
movies uh in a romantic style they all
have the same distribution there are
movies in some other style like action
film okay they're made by
a new different distribution and now you
get a new movie maybe it's not
classified and you know this person you
don't know but so it turns out that this
person likes that and doesn't like that
the new movie comes out you look at some
features
and based on that you want to classify
does that make sense can you expect the
feature bundle to be exactly like a
feature bundle you've seen before
um
okay so what we expect is this so we
expect that there's a distribution so if
you want if you want you can think that
you have decided ahead of time on some
features the features the length of the
movies the names of the actors and so on
so you have some feature space okay and
um there's some distribution uh for the
good the good movies will have some
distribution over the space the bad
movies will have some this another
distribution over the space space now we
don't know these distributions ahead of
time so if you want you can say i
learned them from these maybe we have a
different way of doing it doesn't matter
but one way is to learn the distribution
and learn this distribution and then
once you know the two distributions
we'll talk about what happens if you
know the two distributions maybe you can
make a good decision
what i'm asking is it seems to be that
those examples both have some kind of
topology oh that's right okay very good
okay okay so we'll talk very good okay i
apologize that yeah absolutely so this
is our discrete sets so we have a
distribution of the sweet set uh one of
the things we'll we'll talk about is
when you have topology you'll see we'll
talk a little bit about that as well but
you're you're fully right okay
okay so basically you can argue that
everything in life um
based on the past experience right and
so right okay
okay so um
um
so first let's talk about the omniscient
classifier that's not a scientist that
drives a dodge omni it's a it's a
classifier that knows everything let's
see what that work class if i would do
so this is a classifier that knows p and
q in advance knows the distribution of
of our good movies knows the
distribution of bad movies okay
so in that case uh
the the classifies project that just
becomes hypothesis testing they know the
distribution p they know the
distribution queue z comes in they need
to decide if it was generated according
to p or current q just classical
hypothesis question
oh hypothesis testing forms so what they
can do in this case they don't need to
look at the training data because they
know the distribution it doesn't help
them
okay and they just classify it z to the
distribution that signs it to add to the
higher the higher probability so if if p
of z is let's see if i wrote this down
yeah if pov is bigger than q of z then
we'll associate it with p and if this is
less than q zero we associate with q is
everyone 100
okay with this okay
so so if you knew the two distributions
you always and you assume they're
equally likely the two hypothesis then
look which one assigns more probability
to what you observe and that's what you
should do
okay
all right um
okay so that that is kind of
true
okay
but of course this omniscient classifier
requires knowing p and q in advance
so you need to know the distribution p
and distribution q in advance in reality
that's never no never the case like if
you look at movies you don't know what
is the distribution of good movies the
distribution that is sort of the thing
you want to learn this is maximum
likelihood
this is maximum likelihood no okay so
you're talking about up to here
um before you yeah after a second you're
talking about at this point
it's
it is much more likely not in the sense
that we've um
uh the that yeah you're looking for the
distribution that gives it the higher
probability and that's the one you
select so if that's what you
yeah yeah okay
yes yes that's what i'm saying okay
okay what you were saying too uh no no
because there's a different maximum
likelihood here that uh may not work
which is how you'd up because you i'm
sorry that's why i was asking because
you're asking about here and you need to
learn the distribution and then you can
learn the distributions maximum
likelihood so i wasn't sure
that's okay
all right so um
so it so this requires knowing pnq in
advance and um
and so for any pair
p and q you'll need to use a different
classifier right which you can't because
used to you've a single classifier
so it's impossible
so so let e star of p and q be the error
of the omniscient classifier for p and q
so for every two distribution p and q
there'll be
their omniscient classifier that's
designed based on these two
distributions it's written here and it
achieves an error which is e star this
is star the error is in this case is
simple you look at
all possible value z you look at the
lowest probability you sum them up and
divide by two that's the error of this
classifier but that's not so important
whatever it is it is
right um
and as we said achieving e-star requires
knowing pq in advance so it's impossible
so the question of course is whether a
realistic classifier one that does not
know pnq in advance can approach this e
star
so um so so so so that leads us to
definition of competitive classification
so what we want is a classifier that
performs nearly as well as the
omniscient classifier
and remember e-staff pq is the lowest
error of any classifier for p and q it's
total definition requires known pq in
advance therefore impossible and if you
have a class another classifier c so you
come up with any classifier call it c
then it will for p for p and q it will
make some other error which is e n p and
q which depends on the number of samples
that you have seen estar does not depend
on the number of training samples
because you don't need to even look at
them
so you can think of infinity and now
we're given some some number of samples
n and you come with classifier then this
is the error of this classifier okay
right um
and you can find the degradation of the
classifier within sample to be um
of uh to be the largest error increase
so it's the um
the um the maximum of all
distribution pairs p and q of the error
of this classifier minus the best error
that you can do for this for these two
distributions
exactly so come up with a classifier
call it c
for some maybe for some pnq it will be
optimal but for others it won't be
optimal so you look at this difference
of your error minus the best error and
you look at the worst distribution
possible in terms of this pair of
distribution this e is taking
expectation over all the training that
you can see right it's over uh this is
over all the training and the test
okay
and so this is for the classifier c and
of course we're doing min max so we'll
find the classifier with the lowest
degradation possible and and that will
be just a function of n it's the minimum
of all classifiers of the of the
degradation
clear
okay
so this is the lowest
guaranteeable increase in the error with
n samples
so if you give me n samples i can
guarantee that my error will be
my additional error will be at most
something
okay and
observe that the worst possible increase
is one half it will never be more than
one half because you can always take a
classifier that randomly associates z
with something so its error is one half
the e star is always at least zero
so the difference is at mostly half so
this number d the n is at most half
okay
and the question is whether you can get
dn to be less than a half
example can you get the n to be 0.49 can
you can you build a classifier that you
guarantee
that with n samples like so let's say n
is a million can you
build a classifier that when you give me
m a million samples from x is million
sample from p a million stamp of samples
for q and then classifier your error is
going to be at most 0.49
at most that larger than the best
possible
you know yes
aren't these probabilities exponentially
decreasing
um the if you fix if you fix the p and q
they decrease and they might decrease
exponentially but we're looking you're
fixing n because we don't want to see
everything we're doing is not in what
happens in you know in the limit your
fixed end like n is like a million maybe
even a large number maybe a million and
we want to be able to guarantee
that your increase is not
um
is not high so it's not a question of
exponential because
theorem etcetera you know no because
okay let me show you let me show the
next example
i understand yeah but but the thing is
we're not looking in the regime that we
let n go to infinity we're not doing
things for in for n going to infinity
looking at the behavior we're looking at
n which is a fixed number it could be a
trillion i don't care but it's a fixed
number
why do you use the word always i don't
understand the word always because we're
looking at the maximum of all uh of all
pairs of distribution pq you can you can
come up with with a classifier that will
be very good for two specific
distributions
but will be bad for two other
distributions and the issue is that you
don't know ahead of time what the
distributions are so i want to classify
that will work for every p and for every
queue you also don't have any bound on
the alphabets of people right that's
correct
correct correct and that
we'll see that in the next example and
that's why that's why the exponential
regime will not kick in at that point
and obviously no right
um because
because if you can let k to be arbitrary
large they can probably present some
training which is no information at all
to the classifier right okay okay so
you are fixing then but letting kbr
determine right correct
so so the first thing to see is that
actually you cannot do better than half
the the best you can do it guarantees a
half
so given any n and could be arbitrary
large uh let k be four n so we're making
a k even larger okay and and mind you
this is a reasonable thing like we said
that you know like the size of english
is you know half a million and you need
to look at the con
given the given the
context and so on and let p and q be
uniform uh over disjoint uh subsets of
one up to k so this k is the alphabet
and you take half of it and p is this
joint over one half q is this joint over
another half for example p is disjoint
over the first half and q over the
second half or p is this joint over the
i'm sorry or p is uniform i'm sorry over
the evens and q is uniform over the odds
okay so there's disjoint
pinky or disjoint and uniform okay so
here is for example where k n is five so
we took k to b 20 and then we get p and
q to be uniform over half of the
elements 10 elements disjoint okay so
what is e star
in this case
0 0 0
everyone agrees right because uh because
uh and
because they're disjoint so if we know p
and q
and we see a sample if it comes so we
know
that p is is uh blue and q is
uh red so if the sample if z is blue we
say it's p if q if b is red we say it's
q and this works for any n because we
don't need we know p we know p and q we
don't need to learn them so it doesn't
matter what n is so e star is zero um on
the other hand what is e c if you come
up with any estimator what is the best
error that you
um that that you can guarantee so notice
that n is chosen to be k over four
okay so that implies that the number of
samples that you'll see
every every for every n for every
every time n is the number of training
samples and each any training sample
consists of sample from p and something
from q
so it mostly gets two samples so you'll
see at most k over two
you'll see most k over two samples okay
now the probability that z
uh will not be one of those k over two
samples is at least one half
so for example here we take five or we
take um five samples so maybe this is
the first sample we saw two four six 8
10 we saw 10 samples out of the alphabet
of size 20. the probability that z will
not belong to any of them
is one half
and is
so it's uh it's at least one half and
therefore the error that we'll commit is
at least a quarter because at that point
we need to guess so that implies that
the error is at least a quarter for any
for any um classifier okay and uh so
therefore the best that we can guarantee
is it is at least a quarter and if we
take k to be much much larger than n
then we can get one half right so if you
took it to be like a billion times then
then you get us
as much as as close to a half as you
want it's okay
right okay
so what that tells us is that
um if we look at the best degradation
that we can guarantee it's actually a
half we cannot guarantee doing anything
better than a half years
well like in this case uh in this case
no because i think i think not because
in this case the e star is zero
so if you try to do it multiplicatively
it's even worse
even worse
okay
so um so this falls a little bit in what
we discussed yesterday which was the art
of the durable how can we modify the
problem so to make it
possible okay
and our goal is to modify the problem
one in a way that will make it possible
to in a way that will show that what
good and touring did like looking at the
combined estimation is actually useful
what we discussed yesterday
that we didn't just arbitrarily decide
to combine it's actually useful and
three maybe get some results that that
are nice okay so let's talk about that
so let's talk about label invariant
classification
so um
e-star domination classifier requires
knowing p and q in advance okay and
that's maybe a little too much
our power to give the estimator like
just look compare ourselves to someone
who knows the distribution in advance
nobody knows that so that's a little too
much power maybe to give
this
this uh classifier that we're comparing
ourselves to so no real classifier knows
that much
so maybe you can make a natural
modification uh and compare to more
realistic classifiers and these
classifiers are called label invariant
or canonical also called classifiers so
to see what they are let's look at an
example so again three
three training samples for x and y and
then z
so suppose we the training samples are a
and b and cba and the test is is is a
we'll classify it someplace okay
whatever it is okay
now let's look at
a new sample so now we have
uuv and wvu
and the and the
and the test is you okay
if we have a reasonable classifier what
can we say about the classif the two
classification that this how we'll
classify this one and how we'll classify
this one can you say something about
that
must be the same because we just renamed
things this is a classifier in english
aab and this is classified that a is
using french maybe a is u and b is v and
c is w and so on so there's uh there's
just a relabeling right there's like a
one-to-one mapping from both the the x
the y and the z all of them the same
mapping that a goes to you in all of
them and b goes to v in all of them and
so on
so in that case it's clear that this
classifier should give the same answer
as this classified shouldn't be that
someone who does classification
in greece will do something different
that someone does classification
in i don't know
okay it has to be the same
so uh
what's that
you know the meaning of the language
right or the words no i don't think so
because um we are learning from scratch
so
if you know more
that's
you should incorporate some place
material just giving samples from the
distribution trying to learn
like you're giving emails
you do you have an algorithm you wrote
it in it works for english works for
french
okay
so in both cases classification should
be the same uh so in other words if you
have consistent
relabeling of all of them if you have
just one of them two of them that would
not apply but if you have consistent
relation of all of them then we should
have the same classification
and is this we said called label
environment or canonical classifiers
canonical because
that's the all reasonable classifiers
classifiers are like that
um so if you assume again if you assume
no prior knowledge like david was going
to assume prior knowledge if you assume
no prior knowledge then all natural
classifiers economical
so what we can do is we can just do the
same thing and we can define each
e-star tilde
still they will stand for classifiers
that have to be labeled in variant
okay
um
okay um
so um
and and notice that achieving this
e-star what is tartilda also requires
prior knowledge of pmq you cannot
achieve this
this you cannot achieve this performance
without knowing pmq in advance
okay and we let the end tilde to be the
degradation of the best label
environment classifier compared to the
to the i'm sorry of the best compared to
the omniscient label environment
classifier so again compare
labeling to label invent is it obvious
how to compute this no not not not easy
not not obvious at all you should be
looking at um
essentially the patterns we discussed
yesterday
and but do for both of them so you look
at these symbols how many times how many
symbols appeared three times here and
four times here and appeared here and so
on
algorithm no
no okay no no no no because you need to
look at all possible permutations
so you see why all right you need to
look at all possible permutations of the
symbols
that could give you that
thank you
yes
what does it mean omniscient labeling
so
a label an omniscient um okay a
classifier can be invariant and can be
uh can be variant right it could look at
the values and save the values
like they would
um you know berkeley will do something
else that's that's labeled variant
um you know it takes into account what
the values are a label invariant is such
that if you permute these these things
if you relabel them will give you the
same answer okay
now you can you can try to minimize
there over all classifiers so that's
what we did in the previous slide you
can minimize this error over only
classifiers that are labeled in variant
just can you explain why that one that
minimizes the values of the two is not
labeled in variant just to get some
input on typically or why it's not
labeled okay perfect okay
um let's look let's look at an example
that we had before this example
so if you know the two distributions
then in new pinq namely you know that
this is p this is p this is p this is p
in this case and you know which which is
q note that q was the red one you know
the d is a q okay so now when someone
gives you z
okay
then you look at see whether z is here
or here or here and then you decide okay
this is clearly labeled invent because
here in this example i only gave you
i only gave you five samples
okay i gave you i'm sorry i give you n
was five so you got five times two ten
samples and suppose this was the value
okay the omniscient the i'm sorry the
the our best uh label variant classifier
will classify this into into p because
it sees that okay
but now
um
now supposedly we label this one to this
one so we're not re-labeling any of the
of the training we're just re-labeling
the the the test which did not appear so
it should be classifying into the same
one
because suppose you had
suppose your training was
suppose your training was a
a
a and that one's b b b something b b c
let's say and d something you've not
appeared
let's say this classifies it into this
one okay now i'll change this to
something that that is completely
different here we've not seen it before
if it's labeled invariant it should also
classify it into this one
this is a pathological example where
you're forcing it to be classified the
same way for something that has not been
seen right i mean
um
it's it's uh
um
no uh i wouldn't i don't think so
because i agree that this example is not
maybe super common
but it's easier for us to to describe
this is not what will make things
possible and not possible but i just
want to show you why the label
yeah
you could make things that things appear
a few times and it
this will with this i can explain to you
why it will not work if i had made it
more complicated then you can you should
trust me that it still won't work but it
will be more difficult to show you
because you need to do some calculations
but you agree that this one
if you want to achieve zero error then
it has to be labeled variant
is that okay
yes so uh
in the label invariant case you are
considering only deterministic
classifiers that
uh we're considering that but you can
show that the best classifier will be uh
deterministic um but again so in this
case for example
uh if you do random if you choose p and
q randomly for d which has not appeared
then the worst case it does better than
deterministic right
um
the worst case does better than i'm
sorry
okay so you're saying that even if you
make a deterministic thing it's
it's right
correct
okay yeah we will consider deterministic
but there's no i don't think there's any
reason for you too okay
um
right because you're choosing if you
have a randomized one you can you're
choosing you're averaging over a bunch
of deterministic ones and just look at
the one that gives you the highest one
all right
any
any other questions so it's clear yeah
just to get the number of
times that like
he doesn't get each letter he gets real
number of number of letters which gets
one tile number
that's correct so another way uh so one
way to to say it is that what the way i
said it
that is that you want a classifier that
if you relabel it's
the classification stays the same and an
equivalent way of saying it is what uh
he was saying that you want a classified
just you look at uh you say how many
letters appeared once here and then
twice here and three times here and you
and you just kind of keep those counts
and based on those counts you make your
classification
it's more like the profile that we had
yesterday but but two-dimensional or
three-dimensional feminist words
um
all right
okay um
um
so always also requires to get it also
requires knowledge of p and q
and we said what is the end and then
tilde so we know that dn was half and
the question is whether dn tilde
can be smaller
all right um
and the reason to do this is at least if
you're designing your your classifier
based on the worst case then here one
half you know it's one half it doesn't
give you anything so you need to come up
with a different measure that you say my
classifier is good because it works you
know well in all cases
okay so um
so first
let's show so so again so we'll look
we're trying to look at what dn tilde is
so let's uh let's look at um the
empirical frequency classifier first
um so
um so for example if you have a b c b a
and a we'll classify so we'll look at
the probability that a gets here it's
two thirds here it's one third so we're
going to say it
goes to p
and here we have c so c appeared once
here and twice there so we'll say it
belongs to q okay and the question is so
what is the optimal classifier
so
so
one possible thought is the empirical
frequency classifier we call it f that
assigns the training uh which assigns to
the one we're trying the distribution
based on these training sequences and we
assign the the test to the one with the
highest probability namely we assign to
the training with the more with z
appeared more times
then
um
it kind of takes the distribution that
assigns to z z to z the highest the
higher probability which is what we said
we need to do we need to assign is what
david calls maximum likelihood um we
need to assign z to the distribution
that just gives it the higher the higher
probability okay and you notice that
this is label invariant
this estimator is labeling event if i'm
going to change a a b
and b to alpha and beta and so on it
will still assign the same so this
empirical frequency is labeling vine
so um so it kind of
should be or is it clear that it's
optimal
so optimal means in terms of the
comparative difference correct correct
compared to the label
inverter and correct correct so what do
people think
clearly often so we're here we're still
in the world where k could be much
larger correct okay could be anything
but then it could be that all of so
clearly optimal could be
equally bad as something that is
that is true uh if uh if indeed the n
was one half but maybe in this case it's
not one half
okay but you would still go
yeah i mean that's okay that's one of
many optimal that's okay sorry i'm just
curious
you mentioned these two
senses of label invariant but one of
them is allowed to take into account
when something appears
the location does not matter because
it's iid so
actually you're comparing against the
best one if you're allowed to look
you're cheap you can see that oh
for this particular
condition just just one second uh when
you say where it appeared i'm just going
to make sure i understand do you mean
that a appeared before c or
yeah that we're assuming that the
samples are iid
so
one could say that there could be
another level of uh labeling event or
canonical that you should say that if
you permute those if you mute the
sequences you should also give you the
same answer that will not make any
difference
because it's iid so you should not have
it doesn't you don't gain any
information from the fact that you saw
ccba or if they were like this so if you
want you can live at that level of
obstruction and it will not make a
difference
clearly optimal is still a question mark
or no
that's in my question to you i guess
so okay so
why right i mean
okay so we don't see that it's optimal
right it looks like it could be but but
but maybe not so what will actually show
is that it's not competitive with like
labeling variant classifiers it's
actually not optimal
what does that mean sorry so that means
what that means what that means is that
if you classifier let's your classifier
in this case is this you get a letter
you you look at the test and you try to
classify it look at the sequence where
to look look at x and look at what and
look at why
see wait where this was z this c
appeared more times and classify it
there if that's what you do you're not
you're not uh you're not achieving this
your d star tilde or your error your
degradation is not optimal just to
clarify when there's a tie what do you
do if you have not seen it and then you
so if you if you use the empirical
frequency maybe you just uh randomly
randomly say well
it's not that you will come up with
another one no that's not it's not about
time it's not about ties no it's not
about it no competitive means that
you're not
minimizing that gap correct you can
achieve that uh detail though right so
maybe we'll see maybe you'll see maybe
achieve the question is what is detailed
what is the tilde right so detail there
is some number there may be no scheme
that can achieve these others um
so our definition of detail there is the
one that achieved by the same by the
best scheme so hope is that this d tilde
the tilde goes to with of n it's a
function of n goes down to zero
so we know that we know that d n
with our tilde is one half
and our hope is that d
d n
this thing goes down to zero as a
function of n
okay and and so if if you're looking so
uh what we're going to show now when you
say competitive you may go to zero
um
let's yeah let's say yeah yeah
and you're saying this does not go to
zero correct correct but it's not clear
whether there is anything else yeah
that's right so we we need a little
patience for that
right
and if you bound k like to give much
smaller than earned but that's you could
that's not our interest um in this whole
all three hours three hours what we said
was that
yeah that's right
what people have done in the past we
started
three days ago looked at small k and let
n go to infinity then you get like
exponential
decay and so on that that's all great
but what we're saying is that if you
want to do natural language processing
um you're trying to estimate a
distribution over english words half a
million in a given context the previous
two words the number of such contexts is
let's say half a million square the
number of samples even google has with
that many contexts is very small
compared to half a million so we're not
in the regime that you alphabet that
your that your sample size is much
bigger than k dimensional statistics is
another way
so we will actually everything you do is
see what happens when your alphabet is
large
that's all that's what we're doing okay
so um so what we want to show is that
this is not competitive with label
invite classifier which will make it
clear so even in this competitive the
performance can still sucks right that's
right so it could be it could be
uh so it depends so this is not this is
this is not completely well defined
let's define next slide you say so it's
true it could be that the end that the
end it goes to like maybe one quarter or
maybe goes to one half and the empirical
frequency actually go to more than that
okay but what we'll eventually show is
or at least say is that the best you can
do goes to zero and what we're going to
show now is that empirical frequency
does not go to zero that's what we want
to show here only one sample of z or uh
in this particular case we get a single
symbol z if you wait like 15 minutes
you'll see about more
it's not optimal even if you get only
one sample it's not optimal right
one next slide by the way what you said
yeah we did real really well yesterday
when you're not around there was no time
limit everything
all right okay so um so what we want to
see is a low bound on the error of
empirical frequency classifier we want
to show that if you have a single
single test it's not optimal okay
um so it will show is that uh if you
look at empirical frequency extension f
stands for that
then the um
the degradation compared to other
label invent classifiers at least 1.5
maybe not that much but but not optimal
okay and this is using a simple example
so um let p
be um uniformly distributed on n
elements
and q
uniformly distributed over
the first
two n integers okay
uh so what is the optimal classifier we
know that if p of z is bigger than q z
then we need to uh class send z to p and
otherwise to
if you knew the probabilities
okay um and and in this case it remains
for this for this uh even though we'll
be looking at uh
things that
there's a slightly different calculation
that you need to do but it remains the
same
um
so now remember that x is distributed
equal to p and y according to q so let
n z so these the test of x and be the
number of times z appears in x n okay
so if
n z if
of x n is bigger than equal to one
namely if z appeared in x n
let's build at least one so if z
appeared in x n and what is p of z
if z appeared in x n
what is p of z
remember x
right so so p generates x
so p generates x q generates y
and now it someone tells you that z
appeared in x so that means that z is
one of those first n elements and so p
of z is one over n okay
if z
if z appeared in y and more than once
namely z appeared in y
okay that that means that r q is one
over two n
therefore
therefore if you have an element that
appeared in both of them
appeared in x
at least once and appeared in y
more than once then
then you should associate with with p
which makes more sense because p gives a
higher probability
okay
um
and you also notice that this this
classifier is labeled invariant
right because if you rename things it's
the same
as you classify as if it appears your
classifier says if it appeared in both
of them this is p this is q you'll
associate with me
but let's look at the distribution
um of nz of x and the number of times
that z appears in xn right so
so
we we want to evaluate the performance
of the empirical frequency estimator so
we see how many times it will appear
here in accent how many times it will
appear in mayan and that's going to be
our classification rule
okay
so how many times will z appear in x n
z
um
um it
is uh distributed binomial n and one
over n right because z is some number
that is
uh generated randomly okay
and uh the probability that it will
appear so
z
ah that will appear in um
so
x is length n and the probability that
will appear in any of them
is one over n
okay
and so it's poisson one
let's look at the distribution of z in y
n okay it's binomial when n and one over
two n right because it's um
uh
um
because it's
you have two n values okay and so each
probability is one over two n and you
have to take n samples okay so this is
poisson one half
okay
but
there's some probability that this
number even though it's poisson one half
and this is poisson one there's some
probability that that this n z will be
bigger than one
okay uh and number of times that that
this will be reversed namely that it
will appear in in accent even though
it's possible one fewer times than one
and both of them will be good than one
so there's some probability that this
happens
when this happens you'll be you'll be
assigning it to the wrong one you'll be
assigned it to one where you should be
assigning it to x
okay so in this case you classify to y
instead of x which is what you should
have been you should have done and so
additionally always this probability and
then
times one half but
it's not clear if you see a small so the
maximum likelihood thing classifies all
small numbers in the first
right
okay and the second one says well if you
see a small number you're not 100 sure
it came from the first
i'm sorry so what
so yeah so but but in order to be so in
order to be i'm not sure if that's what
you're saying but in order to be optimal
what you need to do is for every value
of z every combination you need to make
the best decision because your error is
the combination so what we're saying is
that in these cases you did not make the
best decision in all other cases
i don't care what you have done it's
going to be the summation of these
probabilities by here or just on these
you're making at least on this error
yeah yeah but it's not an absurd
decision it's not an absurd decision
it's just not the best decision yeah
okay so yeah so that we're going to see
okay yeah so the question is there's a
better one right
okay that's right so the question is
whether there's a better one
okay so so that shows that that the
that for empirical frequency the uh
additional error over the best label
environment classifier is at least 1.5
percent so that's what i meant when i
wrote vaguely that it's not competitive
so now we understand
okay
so the question is whether it's
something that is competitive okay all
right um okay
so indeed there is
so again so we call the dn with
label not environment but you could not
the best you could do is one half away
and the question is whether you for
labeling invent classifier you can do
better than one half
and um what you can do is you collect
relate this classification to estimation
over sequence pairs because you observe
a sequence of x and y's
and
you
remember that we had
for the what we described last time you
had an estimator that
that when you looked at the combined
probabilities
achieve the best that you can
the error went down to zero okay
and um
and if you look at this second
interpretation in fact so what you have
here is you have you need to look at um
you're not trying to estimate the
distribution of values but distributions
over kind of profiles like so many
symbols appeared three times here and
twice in in y and then here appeared and
so on uh and you try to estimate those
probabilities and and we saw last time
that for single sequences you could you
can do it and you can modify the
estimator to sequence pairs
okay i'm not showing this
uh and using that you can actually build
the label invariant classifier which
here is it goes like at most one over n
to the one over five
so this
does not depend on k
it doesn't matter what k is what the
alphabet size is you can you can achieve
it
so you can build a classifier
so we know that if you try to compare
with compare someone who knew the exact
distribution that's impossible that you
gave that person too much power
but um you know um
uh you know if you um
if you just try to compare to yourself
to someone who knew the um
is either label invariant
or you can say someone knows like the
distribution up to a permutation
then actually you can come up with a
classifier that that is competitive
so this is what that shows so so uh i
don't know there's uh uh you know
superman superwoman you know catwoman or
something so maybe if you want to be
superwoman you cannot compete but when
you don't with catwoman then maybe you
can so it's that kind of thing you can
you can compete you cannot compete with
some superhumans but you can still
compete with some other superhumans that
are still stronger than anyone we know
so
that's what this does so it's
approaching performance domination label
environment classifier it's a uniform
bound of the arcade there's no k in this
and and that classifier works in linear
time just like all these estimators and
so as we know it's the first uniformly
competitive classifier
can you explain what that classifier
would do in the example
so what you need to do is you need to do
the good i described to you how the good
touring estimating will work so you need
to look at that and do this this
calculation is a little tricky and then
you need to also do it over sequences of
pairs of sequences so it's not easy
it's at least as complicated as the good
touring estimator does okay
why would it do better in that last
example so let me ask you let's let me
ask you another question so you remember
the good touring estimator that what
they did was it looked at um
it looks at
empirical frequency essentially and it
looks at the next one
why would that be better than the
empirical frequency
it's the same kind of reason that you
actually
uh
so in other words in order to explain
this this is this is a complete this is
a complication on good touring because
you need to estimate two sequences at
the same time
in order to understand why this will
work better than
empirical frequency it's easier to
explain why good touring will work
better than empirical frequency on a
single sequence
do you understand that probably no
so so one should better explain that and
that will take a little bit of time so
in fact in fact um
you guys asked that i would give like um
an open talk there's an open talk coming
up and it will be about good turning
estimator so if you can wait till then
i'll try to do my best to explain why
good touring works better than me
but it's it's not are there many
explanations for good doing you can look
look at them
um
none of them is like i can tell you in
one word um
if you want i can try in like three
sentences maybe at the end just because
i can try to tell you but i'm not going
to do much justice to this one okay
the question is you see you have two
samples
and you see how many times like an
element appeared the question is should
this not this probability that you sign
should it be a monotone in the number of
times this element appears and the good
touring they tell you no you should look
at how many things how many times other
things have appeared as well it's very
unintuitive but it's
true um i'm just touring after all yeah
that's right that's why you make a movie
about that and not about uh incredible
frequency all right uh okay
all right okay so um
okay so here there's also a low bound
you can prove a low bound but
the bounds are not matching the upper
and lower bounds so there's a little bit
of gap so you didn't explain yesterday
why touring skeleton was good no i did
not yeah
what we did explain yesterday was one
one aspect but i don't think that's what
he's asking about we showed that good
touring is unbiased that's the first
part of the explanation but that's not
the kind of explanation he's looking for
this explanation is in terms of if
you're going to prove things you need to
prove the device i agree with uh
announced that we're nice to have a
direct explanation
right because empirical frequency is so
intuitive
and now you're telling people a very
shocking result we say that you can do
better
now you should be able to explain it
directly in that example why you i agree
but what so what i'm just saying is in
order to explain this this example
an easier thing to explain is why the
probability that we're assigned to an
element should not be just a function of
the number of times this element appears
it should be a function of other things
as well
because if you remember good touring
assigns the two things that appeared
five times it decides what empirical
frequency gives two things up here six
times why should we care
um so yeah so in this in the example
before any any estimator that has an
error that goes to zero must assign the
small numbers asymptotically to the
first class right is that correct
correct because otherwise you can't so
there must be a reason and
this thing will see that all the small
numbers must be coming from right but
asymptotically notice the
sympathetically empirical frequency will
also do the same right we just chose n
was the number of samples and k was
either n or 2n
in this example so it was not in the
asymptotic regime the number of samples
is much larger than the alphabet sizes
are actually same or smaller than the
alphabet size but yeah sympathetically
asymptotically good turing will converge
to empirical frequency if you didn't
there was there would have been logical
error
frequency will will not right because
the the the
even as n grows
the empirical frequency when you see at
the small number with with a constant
chance you will always assign it to the
big thing no so the the thing is no no
just just one second so maybe maybe
we're not talking about the same thing
when i say n grows i'm thinking you're
fixing the distribution
you're fixing the distribution and like
the number of sample grows if that's
what you're doing as the number of
sample goes to infinity you'll estimate
the distribution correctly
do you think have the here
to
with at least a constant chance that's
correct yeah yeah this solves for any n
this holds for any n i thought you meant
asymptotically like we've you know
the small numbers to the big
distribution and that's why it's making
an error correct
so any any estimator that will have a
vanishing error
will will will let we learn as n grows
in your example to assign all the small
numbers
to the small distribution what it will
do what you will do is it will look so
in this case um you
you can learn more
uh because you can see the more there's
more structure to this distribution
right if things if you have n samples
and you have a distribution over n
things you'll see one kind of
distribution not just by looking at at
your sample and if you have n samples
over two and you'll see a different kind
of uh spread and this estimator will
learn that even though it does not you
didn't tell it ahead of time that it's
over n and two examples but you will
learn that there are different things
and we'll learn that
so it will take that into account right
okay so so yes so so if you want come to
the other talk and you'll hopefully
understand but you need to understand
first why why good touring works better
than empirical frequency and then you'll
you can try to look at that all right
okay um
okay so um
okay so i think at this point you have
so many questions i should ask you at
least two and this should be easy for
you so so we said that you can approach
the
you can approach the best performance
like up to one over n to the one five
and how can we do it approach it for the
remember we had an example of this joint
support how so this says maybe that we
should be able to approach the best
error which was zero but we argued that
you cannot your error will be at least
actually one quarter or something so how
can we is the contradiction here between
this and the first example so if the two
examples have this joint support
the best you can do is zero
uh but
that's right label inverse so we know
that so so in order to get zero in the
other one you need like we wrote here
labeling label variant classifier but if
you did the label invariant classifier
you will not get and be able to get
there
catwoman
and uh and the second thing this you
know these are legacy slides so this
used to be one talk so what is k now we
need to go back uh three slides three
three talks and remember that's too much
i think even for me so
all right
confuse us
you weren't here at that time that's
right that's right there's a signal
right it's
sigma or what's your notation uh i
didn't try it yeah that's right i
understand right
right okay so i just i just want to show
you an experiment
so um
um
i'm sorry i'm saying because uh
always
time estimation there's no way
so
okay so some experiments i want to
adjust our expectations okay so i know
david is very excited doing something
very um
unintuitive or whatever what you call it
so maybe you think that social
experiment maybe you think that using
this you'll be able to reduce the error
from you other you make an error fifty
percent and reduce it to one percent
okay no if that was the case we could
take an estimator that as fifty percent
reduce one percent i would not be
presenting to you
so um so just
recall the netflix challenge okay they
asked people to improve on their
estimators and they said okay they gave
people i know a certain period of time
and said if you prove our estimate by 10
then you stop stop the game ten percent
is sufficient and give you one million
dollars okay and i don't think it
happened i think it actually continued
um so so ten percent improvement on
things that people have done been doing
for like the last three hundred years
ten percent is is quite a bit of
improvement so don't expect more than
ten percent
okay all right so uh okay so given that
uh-huh
um look let's look at z distributions so
the
looking at two distribution one is one
over i and one is one over i to the one
point five okay so this the distribution
of common distribution is for the
distribution of words okay so look at
two this zip distribution one is linear
and one is one y to the one point five
is k um
um
jay kumar's alphabet size is 100 is
pretty modest i'm not even saying let's
look at a trillion just look 100 very
small number if it works here then it
will work for larger numbers too okay so
what we're doing is we're going to plot
the
error versus the training length n for
empirical frequency and for this for
this proposed classifier
so here they are so this is the number
of samples that you train on
okay
and this is the error probability okay
and so
all right this is what empirical
frequency does and this is what this
estimator does so if you see for example
450 if you train on 50 samples then you
go down from something like 43 percent
to something like 39
so you reduce it by four percent which
is 10 for 10 percent of your error which
is
the netflix limit so
yeah
we gave ourselves a million dollars and
the new limit
the netflix
right so and it's so so so what this is
supposed to show that these things are
not just like asymptotic as you know k's
the trillion and n is a billion and so
on this works for for small numbers as
well so um
so i think so i was i had actually i
have a whole bunch of i i see i have
another
50
so
andrea seems to be relaxed i think
there's only one person here
all right okay but so maybe i'll stop
you so maybe just just uh briefly tell
you uh i was going to tell you some
other results or some some results that
we have is you asked if this is we have
n and n and one but you can ask what if
you have nnn so
what kind of results you get there so if
i give you like one email and another
email and then a third email you want to
classify
um so that's one thing i was going to
talk about um
closeness so this is classification
another problem is closeness testing
someone gives you two two samples and
you and you ask do they come from the
same distribution or from two different
distributions
like you see two manuscripts the same
person write them or two different
people wrote them so this prompt turns
out to be very close to this to this
point we're going to see how they're
related
so so the same techniques will hold
um i was going to talk about
estimating rainy entropy so that's a
very recent work that i mentioned in
himanshu
um so um
it's
people have been trying to estimate
shenan entropy for a long time
some years back um peninsula show so
people knew how to estimate linear
number of distribution of a size k after
estimated entropy with a linear linear
and k number of samples then some years
back poninsky showed that you can
actually do it with number which is
sub-linear and then
pollen um greg valiant showed that you
can do it with alphabet says k with k
over log k samples
and then nihong who is here uh
improve this result and show
really what what is essentially the best
you can get that's a very recent paper
last few months i think
um so whatever it is it's
if not k it's k over low k and once you
get from k to k velocity then you should
ask young what is the what is his
constant and i asked him yesterday and
he was noncoming to like when you when
you look at k over lock a when you try
to estimate what is the constant in
front that you might expect
if you want to get absolute beats
but i'm asking actually what is the the
constant in front
hello is some huge number it's a huge
number so so you're gaining a factor
flow k and you might be losing
a large number so but any case this is a
great these are great results i mean um
but but but but but still you need the
number that is this linear
all
reasonable k
uh a number that let's say is linear or
close to linear so the question is again
in the sense of the art of the durable
maybe instead of shannon entropy is a
measure for end of randomness but who
says you want to look at the shannon
entropy you can also look at rainy
entropy okay so so our rainy entropy
is uh generalizes shannon entropy it has
a parameter and for if look at the value
of the parameters this alpha goes to one
it's actually the shenan entropy but you
can look at different
different ranges of the parameter and
what uh himanshu's question was uh what
if we tried to estimate the um
the rainy entropy and then you can show
that if you try to estimate or any
entropy of integer orders then actually
you need a lot less than linear so for
example uh rainy entropy of order two
you need only square root of k samples
so
i was just going to mention this result
anyways because uh he there is going to
be on in march is going to be the the
workshop and he's going to uh talk about
that so things like that uh and then um
correct for for k equals to two it's
related to collision probability correct
exactly
and some work that ashkan has worked on
which is uh trying to do looking at
continuous distributions they have few
modes and so they don't go all over the
place but they have few modes and how do
you what how can you deal with those so
the results for all these kinds of
things we don't have time to
go over so um
yeah so i think and and while on and you
know like advertising just one last
advertisement i actually made beautiful
slide and got lost when i turned off my
laptop
so in two weeks um
there's going to be the ita workshop in
san diego
and david invites everyone right
to his
hotel room right
okay so
it's actually a really good program we
um we uh
until last year we went like two four
four parallel sessions this time we have
to go to six parlor sessions um
uh there are lots of people from
different fields computer science the
over 90 people i counted participating
over 90 yeah
uh participate participate well we
actually actually have over 500
presenters so uh
so and it's in a beautiful place it's in
the those are the slides that i was
going to show you um
it's it's in one of the beautiful
location most beautiful locations in
california the uh scripps pier and sonic
la jolla but specific part of la jolla
and we have some sessions on
entrepreneurship including a play did
you see there's uh
the uh entrepreneur it's a new it's a
a new play and and actually alex is
organizing um
organizing
what music video yeah
ita vision yeah so it's been posted
right so right so if you can you know
make videos uh you can make game uh you
can maybe get big prizes that yeah alex
so so if you like a netflix challenge
yeah
the worse the video the better of you
better your chances are so anyways
please try to come and uh you know if
we we still have a few slots so if you
want to speak um let people know and
anyway so if people have more questions
i can answer them but if not
stop
last
we went through a lot to come to give
these talks so
really appreciate it
lost yourself yeah that sounds
weird
and so forth and now we lost the
past lives
the classifier you propose always better
than the independent classifier or can
it be
you can show that it's essentially
almost
essentially always almost optimal but it
could be that for some things the
empirical will be better but but not by
much
so you know in other words of asking the
same question more completely is there a
way that i can feed and get the red line
above the blue line for
or
you might be able you might be able to
get it above but not by much
not very much
some of these things still need to be
analyzed exactly but yeah but not by
much because we show that it's uh for
every pq it's almost optimal that's
that's the essence of the proof right so
you have from just just to
to
be a little serious for a second so we
have this right so it's at most end to
the 1.5 so so this is by how much the
other one could be better no more than
that
if you continue your picture on the next
slide you have kind of just i mean we
know that
yeah so eventually eventually you'll get
to the regime that outdoor was
i'm sorry project erdogan was asking
about both of them are going to converge
to zero actually not to zero both of
them in this case because you have a
single one so you'll not but they'll
convert to the same thing because you'll
learn the distribution
so it'll converge to the summation of
the minimum so
as n goes to infinity if you keep the
distribution
and n goes to infinity you learn the
distribution
right so then once you learn the
distribution back to the hypothesis
testing and then it's summation of the
minimum of the two probabilities that's
what you mean because because you're
doing a single you're doing a single
classifying a single element like you
was asking not z is just one element so
you should be able to make more
impressive pictures by
possibly possibly i'm not i'm not sure
possibly
uh yeah i'd like to see the most
impressive
i would like to beat the netflix
competition right
right okay yeah
okay so let's take a thanks
again